[MUSIC PLAYING]
MEL WELLS: My name is Mel.
It's so lovely to meet you.
It's so lovely to see so many
faces here at Google for me
today.
I was a little bit
nervous about this talk,
so I'm really grateful
for a great turnout.
So I'm an author,
and I'm a speaker.
And I help women, primarily,
heal their relationships
with food so they can go on
and lead fulfilled and enriched
lives without waiting
to lose weight first.
And it's mainly
women that I help.
And I believe it's
mainly women that
struggle with their
relationship with food
because we tend to be
more sensitive to being
led by our emotions in general.
We tend to be more
intuitive on a whole.
That's generalizing, obviously.
But you might not even
realize that you're
in a relationship
with food unless you
are in a really unhealthy
one that is taking
over your life in some way.
But actually, your
relationship with food
is just as old as you are.
So if you are 30 years old,
your relationship with food
is also 30 years old.
And your relationship with
food is really made up
of all of your beliefs,
stories, memories around food
and your weight and
your body that you've
had your whole life, really.
Could have been
something that someone
said to you one
day that triggered
a feeling or an emotion.
Could have been
something that you read.
Could have been the latest
diet magazine you picked up.
And all of this constitutes
this huge relationship with food
that you have.
And it probably doesn't
come as a surprise to you
to realize that the reason
that I got into doing this work
and helping women with
their relationship with food
and making peace with
food was because I
was in a really unhealthy, quite
abusive relationship with food
for a long period of my life.
So I'll tell you a bit
about my story first.
So I grew up never
really having any issues
around food or my weight.
My mom was quite healthy,
let us have the odd treat.
The household was very healthy.
My mom never criticized
her body, so,
I knew that she never dieted.
She was very much at peace.
And I was quite a confident
kid, really loved my life,
was really happy at
school, had friends,
was in the sports teams.
It felt like my
teachers liked me.
And I really just
was very carefree.
And I remember walking
across the playground once.
And you know the
girls at school--
how bitchy that was?
Do you guys remember?
it was a very catty
kind of atmosphere.
And I walked across
the playground.
And a girl from one of
the years above me said--
not directly to me, but just
loud enough that I could hear--
she said, oh, that girl, Mel?
She loves herself.
And I felt like someone had
punched me in the stomach.
I felt like that is the worst
thing that anyone could have
ever said to me or about me.
I love myself?
I was like, how dare I be
that girl that loves herself.
No one wants to be that person.
And at that age, you
really just want to fit in.
You don't want to be
too loud or too big
because you just want to fit in.
And at that point, I
remembered to think to myself,
I am not going to be the
girl that loves herself.
Anyway, I was determined
to be an actress.
And I left school and
went to college at 16
to do performing arts.
And when I got there, it was
this really harsh industry
where it was really competitive.
And you're basically
spending eight hours a day
in front of the
mirror, being taught
to look for flaws
and imperfections.
It's a very
perfectionist industry.
And I was already a natural,
high-achiever perfectionist,
which I'm sure probably
some of you are in here.
And all the girls
around me at college
were pinching themselves in the
mirror, going on these diets.
And I just really
wanted to fit in.
So I basically started
dieting as a way
to fit in with the
girls around me
because I didn't want to be
the girl that loved herself.
I didn't want to be the
one that was too confident
and didn't need
to do any of that.
So I basically started
dieting as a way to fit in.
And it was in that era
of the size zero thing.
There was no Kim Kardashian.
There was no big booties
and squats and any of this
that it is nowadays.
That size zero thing
was really glamorized.
And it was a really unhealthy
environment for teenage girls
and for women to be in.
And I remember going
on the Special K diet.
Does anyone remember
the Special K diet?
Anyone do it?
Oh, my God.
Dreadful.
So basically, the
Special K diet,
for anyone that
doesn't know, was a way
to lose a dress
size in two weeks.
And basically, you got
a bowl of Special K
for breakfast, a bowl
of Special K for lunch,
and then you got to have
whatever you wanted for dinner.
Magic, right?
Except it wasn't a bowl of
Special K. It was a handful.
It was like the smallest
handful you could imagine.
And so I remember measuring
out this bowl of Special K
every morning.
And it was literally
the smallest bowl
you could imagine.
And Special K,
obviously, geniuses
because they realized
that if women
were going to believe that
Special K was their diet
food, then they
were going to end up
overeating and binging
on Special K, which
is exactly what happened.
Before I knew it, I was
getting through boxes and boxes
and boxes of Special K.
So me being a
perfectionist and getting
into diet culture
at a very young age,
it wasn't long before I
took it to the extreme
and developed a full-blown
eating disorder.
I lost a lot of
weight very fast.
I restricted myself so
much that at one point,
I couldn't even
remember the last time
I had a proper solid meal.
I was completely spaced out.
I went to a really
dark place, isolated
all my friends and family.
But for some reason, I
felt like I was in control.
I felt like I was making
a success of this.
I felt that I was doing
really well at this.
And I do believe that
an eating disorder is
a form of addiction.
And that is absolutely
how it felt.
So what happened next
was I got offered this TV
job, this acting
job, which sounded
like the most exciting thing
ever to me because I was 18.
And most of my friends were
going off to drama school
and uni and taking gap years.
And I've just been offered this
TV job straight out the gate.
And it should have
been a dream come true.
I took my whole life
up to Liverpool,
moved out of my parents' house.
I suddenly had this flat.
I had money.
I was going out
to these parties.
And I was getting to
act every day on set.
It should have been the dream.
But you know when--
I'm sure you've heard
this story before--
everything should
have been great
and it looked on the outside
like it was really glamorous?
But on the inside, it was not.
It was that empty, sinking
feeling of, oh, my God.
This is not it.
And my eating swung from
barely eating anything
to suddenly excessive binging.
And I'm talking like inhaling
food like I had never seen food
before in my whole life.
I was inhaling it
like it was oxygen.
And I felt such guilt
and shame over this
and for gaining weight so
fast again that I would then--
it swung into bulimia.
And I would be making myself
sick or over-exercising,
taking all kinds of illegal
fat burners off the internet,
and just really
punishing myself so much
and then swearing to start
the next diet the next Monday
morning.
And my producer actually called
me up to the office once.
And she sat me down
and said to me, Mel,
we really need to
talk about something.
Your weight-- it's
all over the place.
On screen, one episode,
you're this size.
The next episode,
The next episode, you're
back to this size.
Continuity doesn't really
know what to do with you.
And the wardrobe department have
got all these different sizes
for you.
Do you need to talk to someone?
And I thought I had been doing
a really great job of keeping
it secret, but obviously not.
And it was so embarrassing
to feel like everyone knew.
And I was completely crushed.
And that night, I went
home, ran back to my flat,
got down, sat on the couch,
and picked up the phone.
Hey.
Yeah, it's Mel.
I got to order three
large pizzas, please.
Yep, stuffed crust.
And when the delivery guy
came, I opened the door.
And he started laughing at me.
And he was like, these three
pizzas all for you, lady?
You know when someone's
joking but not?
So I closed the door, sat
down with these pizzas.
And one by one, I demolished
every single one of them
until I was in so much
physical pain I couldn't move.
I've never felt so full and
yet so empty at the same time.
And then I would,
of course, swear
to start this brand new diet
and fix myself the next day.
Because diets are what
would fix this, right?
Now, you might have never
experienced an eating disorder
or disordered eating.
But a lot of these
addictive patterns
show up in much
more subtle ways.
How many of you guys
have ever gotten home
from a really stressful
day, and before you've even
taken your shoes off, you're in
the fridge looking for answers,
looking for that
fix of something?
And I believe when we do this.
It's not the food
that's the problem.
It's the symptom of
a much deeper problem
that we need to get to
the bottom of and heal.
You see, if your
relationship with food
was a relationship
with a partner,
what kind of relationship
would that be?
For me, it was a very abusive
relationship, not a loving one,
not a healthy one.
Maybe your
relationship with food
is really stale
and really boring.
Maybe it's really
strict during the week,
and then it's just this crazy
party or binge on the weekend.
Maybe it is really monotonous,
the same thing all the time.
Maybe it needs a
bit of spicing up.
You see, food isn't just
nourishment anymore for us.
It isn't just fuel.
We make it means so
many other things.
It's the closest
thing to us that feels
like a substitute for love.
So it's really easy to
turn to it to control it
when we feel out of
control of our lives.
It's the easiest
thing to turn to it
when we're feeling
emotional or when
we're feeling any kind of
uncomfortable or painful
feeling that we just
don't want to feel.
We want to escape.
And us humans are wired to
seek pleasure and avoid pain.
So it's something that we're
all doing all the time.
And it's not
necessarily a bad thing.
Seeking pleasure and
using food as comfort,
as reward, as love--
it might have saved us a
lot of pain and heartache.
But actually, what it does
is it doesn't actually
take away the pain.
It just numbs it and
delays it for later on.
And then we develop these
unhealthy relationships
with food and try and go on
diets trying to fix them.
So if you imagine an iceberg--
and the tip of the
iceberg is the only part
that's above the surface.
The tip of the iceberg is
like what you're actually
eating day to day, what you're
actually putting in your mouth.
But the whole iceberg
underneath the surface--
that is your entire relationship
with food, the psychology
of why you eat, how you eat,
who you are as an eater, what
your identity is around
food, all of those beliefs,
all of those memories, and
all of your relationships,
your career, how fulfilled
you feel in your life.
Because all of
that dictates what
you end up eating and your
behaviors around food.
So I kept thinking the
perfect diet will fix this.
I just need to find
the perfect diet.
When I found the perfect
diet, then I'll be healed.
I'm sure that my food
combining is all off.
Or I'm sure that I'm just
having too many carbs.
Or I'm sure that I'm having
too much fruit or too many
good fats or
whatever it might be.
I'm sure that I'll
find the perfect diet.
And then what
happened was my dad
was given four months to live.
And he was diagnosed
with terminal cancer.
And obviously, this
completely shattered me
and completely shook my world.
And he started reading
books on cancer.
He was very intellectual
and read so many books.
And he started
reading about cancer
knowing that he was dying.
And I started doing same.
And because I was already
obsessed with food,
the books that stood out to
me were cancer prevention,
lifestyle, diet.
And before I knew it,
I had been engulfed
in some books that told me
that veganism was the best
way to reduce your cancer risk.
So?
I was like, oh, my God.
This is it.
I found the perfect diet.
This has got to be it.
This is my answer.
And I felt so much
guilt and shame
that I had found what I thought
was the holy grail to late
to be able to save my dad.
My dad couldn't even keep
food down at that point.
So after he died, I thought,
I've got to share this message.
I've got to go
out into the world
and tell everyone
about veganism.
And because I was
a perfectionist
and because I still
had disordered eating,
I didn't do this by halves.
I didn't just go vegan.
I went gluten free.
I went fat free.
I went sugar free.
I cut out caffeine, no alcohol.
I pretty much cut everything
out until I was just
eating fruit and veg.
And even then, I was worried.
Am I eating too many fruits?
Because it's sugar, isn't it?
So I still had this really
negative relationship
with food.
And I didn't even
realize until one day,
I discovered that I was binging
on a tub of almond butter
and dates.
And I realized that I
was still restricting
by going on juice cleanses.
And I thought, yeah,
I haven't actually
fixed anything here, have I?
My eating disorder
just has another face.
And this is actually something
that I see is really common.
And at the moment in
the wellness industry,
we take things a
step too far instead
of finding peace with
ourselves and peace with food.
So I realized this.
And me and my then
partner were having
talks about getting pregnant
and trying for a baby.
And the thought of this was
such a new thought for me.
And it completely shook me.
Because I remember looking
in the mirror at my body--
this body that I had
spent years at war with--
and thinking, OK.
If I'm going to grow a human in
here, something has to change.
Because if I have to grow
a human baby in here,
I know that I can't keep
treating my body the way
that I am.
I can't restrict.
I can't be binging.
I can't be using food
in these abusive ways.
I need to find a peaceful place
with myself and with my body
and with food
because I can't grow
a human baby on juice cleanses
and fruits and vegetables.
I can't grow a human baby if
I'm binging on the weekend
and then starving
myself in the week.
And then I thought, OK.
If I wouldn't do that for
a child that's imaginary,
why would I not do
that for myself?
Why have I not been doing that
for myself all these years?
And I thought to myself,
you're not ready.
You're not ready for a child.
You need to focus on
loving and nourishing
your body without child first.
And if you can do
that for a year,
then maybe we'll talk about it.
And so I went on this
journey of self love.
And I chucked away my scales.
And I basically started
inspecting my relationship
with food one belief at a time.
Every time I felt a
fear or anxiety come up
around a certain food, I
would question it and go,
where did this come from?
Is this truth?
Is this a story or belief
that I want to keep believing
and want to keep
playing out in my life?
Because at that
time, my head was
so full of all of this
overwhelming information
about nutrition and about
which diet is the best.
And I was hearing this
person talk about veganism,
this person talk about paleo,
this person talking about
quitting sugar, this person
talking about the Dukan diet,
5:2, intermittent
fasting, all this stuff.
And I was like, oh, my God.
My brain is just full.
I just need to let it all go.
And it was just the most
liberating thing ever.
So I want to just do a
little exercise with you guys
if you don't mind.
And it's about beliefs.
And it's about these kind
of diet culture beliefs
that we take on as truth and
then express ourselves with.
So I just want to
raise a show of hands
if any of these beliefs
ring true for you
or if you have ever believed
any of these to be true.
And there's absolutely
no judgment, by the way,
because I believed
all of them are more.
So have you ever believed
that food is the enemy?
Have you believed that fat
in food will make you fat?
Have you believed that you
should count your calories
Monday to Friday, but on the
weekends, calories don't count?
How many of you believed
that sugar is evil?
Carbs are terrible?
That one comes from the
Atkins diet, I think.
How many of you
guys have believed
that if you have one
bad food in the day,
you may as well write
off the rest of the day
because it doesn't
matter, right?
You just try again on Monday.
How many of you believe that
diets have to start on Monday?
There's no other day.
Right.
So now, if you had a
little girl or a boy,
and they came up to
you and they said,
mom, diets have to
start on Monday.
Or, mom, this food is bad.
And if I eat it, I can just eat
all the rest of the bad foods
and then start again tomorrow.
Or if they came up
to you and they said,
thin people are automatically
happier people--
that's another one-- would
you believe that is healthy
for your child?
Would you want that for them?
Would you?
But we accept that for
ourselves all the time.
So my moment of
transformation came when
I thought about having a child.
And suddenly, my picture
became bigger than just myself.
Because when you
are really consumed
with food and diets
and weight loss,
it's a really tunnel
vision way to live.
You don't see the big picture.
You just think you're only here
to lose weight and get down
to a number.
And then your life
can magically begin.
How many of you
guys have believed
that if you get to a
certain number on the scale,
suddenly you'll be happy
and confident and free
and all your dreams
will come true?
I kept doing that.
And I got down and
down and down and down,
and it never happened.
I was like, where
is this feeling?
Where are all the
rainbows and butterflies?
I thought I was supposed to
feel amazing at this number,
and I don't.
I still feel empty.
And it was because
I hadn't really
addressed the problem, which
was I didn't love myself.
So what that girl said to
me on the playground, that
is what I needed to do more than
anything-- was to actually love
myself.
And what I've discovered is
when you make peace with food
and go on that journey,
you're actually
making peace with yourself.
Because healing your
relationship with food
is healing your
relationship with yourself.
Because your
relationship with food
is a reflection of your
relationship with you.
So these addictive
tendencies that we have--
they are not something that we
should be condemning at all.
Rather, these addictive
tendencies-- and that
could be emotional eating.
That could be a glass of wine
at the end of a stressful day.
That could be feeling
anxious, refreshing Instagram,
which is something that I notice
that I do still, for sure.
They're not something that
we should be condemning.
But they are like
our teachers shining
a light on where we
maybe need to look at,
where our souls are actually
hungry for something
even deeper than what we're
trying to fill it up with.
So at the time of this
moment of realization for me,
I was in a relationship
that I didn't really
feel able to fully be myself in.
It looked great on the outside,
but it didn't feel like me.
I was in a job that, again,
looked quite glamorous
on the outside.
But I didn't feel
like it was me.
And I was living in a city
that didn't inspire me.
And all the friends
that I had in my life
didn't feel like real
deep friendships.
So I would say that I was
living a life that did not
feel completely fulfilled.
So I was turning to food
and these outside sources
to try and fill myself up
from the outside in instead
of filling myself up
from the inside out.
And when I went on this journey
of self-love, what I discovered
was it wasn't just about
me healing my relationship
with food.
It was actually about
me transforming my life.
Because then, I
developed such a sense
of self-love and self-worth
that I had the confidence
to do things like leave my
relationship, change my life.
And then I went on to help
other women do the same.
So then I wrote my book.
I started working with clients.
I wrote my online program,
started running retreats.
And it was all because
I decided to take back
my life when it came to food
and love and accept myself.
And around that time, my
ex's sister said to me, Mel,
I feel sorry for you because
you're just not satisfied
with a normal life, are you?
And I was like, I'm
not sure if that's
an insult or a compliment.
Yeah, you know, I
guess you're right.
I'm not satisfied
with a normal life.
She said, you're
always hungry for more.
And I was like, God
damn, you're right.
I am.
And I don't think
that's a bad thing.
And I don't think I was
ungrateful for what I had.
But I think if you feel like
your life is not filling you
up, if you feel like
you're living in a life
that you should be
really grateful for
and everyone else
says, oh, you should
be so lucky and grateful, but
you don't feel like it's yours,
you feel like there's
more out there for you,
then that is your job.
That is your mission
to follow that voice.
to follow that calling.
So our addictions
are not something
that we should be condemning.
They are teachers.
And they can help guide
us in the direction
of where we're supposed to go.
For example, if we can
get curious about them
and observe them, they can
teach us things about our life
where we are maybe
out of alignment.
So maybe, for
example, you get home
from a really
stressful day at work.
And on the way home,
you find yourself
in the newsagent's
grabbing a chocolate bar.
So maybe that's not that
you've got terrible willpower.
Maybe, actually, the root
of that is stress at work.
So maybe that is I need to set
more boundaries around work.
Or I need to destress.
Or I need to meditate
in the mornings.
Or I need to decide to make
a decision that I'm not
going to work with this kind
of project or this person.
Or maybe it's a change
of job on a bigger level.
Maybe you're hungry for
change in your life.
Maybe if you notice that when
that guy doesn't call you back
or that guy doesn't
text you back,
it makes you want to
binge eat all of a sudden.
Maybe that's not because
you were just greedy.
Maybe that's because
actually what
you're really hungry
for on a deeper level
is love, intimacy, connection.
So maybe that is actually a sign
that you need to give yourself
more love, that you need to
give yourself more time, more
intimacy with you and
work on the relationship
you have with yourself,
which is obviously
the most important relationship
of our whole lives.
I was walking home
from a class of a day.
It was a 45-minute walk.
And I blame Google for
this because I literally
have no idea how to
walk anywhere in London
without Google Maps.
I'm completely reliant on it.
And I came out of this
class, and I had to get home.
And my battery was on 1%.
And I started walking home.
And I literally had no idea
where I was going apart
from with the Maps on.
And then my phone died.
And I instantly felt that
feeling of disconnection.
And then I noticed my mind
go, oh, I'll go to [INAUDIBLE]
and get a chocolate bar.
And I was like, oh, my God.
It's happening to me right now.
I just wrote a book on this.
Practice what you preach.
OK.
This is teaching me
that I feel disconnected
when my phone dies.
This is teaching me to find
a deeper connection offline.
So this is teaching
me that I need
to find a deeper connection with
myself, with a higher power,
get into nature, meditate more.
Things that I do
to feel connected
are journaling,
getting into nature,
going to the park with
a book, or praying.
And so I had a little
taste of my own lessons
there, which I found
really interesting.
So what is really
cool is addictions
are not necessarily bad.
It's really about a lack of
connection or fulfillment
that creates them.
So there was a study
done on rats in the '70s.
You might have heard of it.
And basically, one
rat was put alone
in a cage with two
bottles of water.
One was just water.
And one was water
laced with cocaine.
And every time they
ran this experiment--
which was about addiction--
every time they ran
this experiment,
the rats would choose
the drugs, get addicted,
and eventually die.
But Professor Bruce
Alexander came along,
saw this experiment, and
thought to himself, well,
the rat is alone in a cage.
But rats are social
creatures, just like humans.
And they thrive off interaction
and connection with other rats.
So he thought, if a human
was alone in a cage,
wouldn't the human
choose the drugs
if they were offered it
just for something to do?
So basically, he decided to
build this rat park, which
was like a haven for rats.
They had all their rat friends.
They had rat games.
They had rat food.
They had rat "Love
Island" on TV.
They were living their
best lives, these rats.
And then they put in
these two bottles of water
again, the one with
the water and the one
with the water
laced with cocaine.
Can you guess what happened?
They rejected the
drugs completely.
They chose just the water.
And he concluded that this
was because they were living
fulfilled lives .
They felt connected.
They didn't feel isolated.
They had a purpose
in their lives.
So I think this is
just fascinating.
And we can link this back to
food or alcohol or anything
else that we use as a drug
to numb our pain often.
So what this means
is when you're
feeling a lack of connection
or lack of fulfillment
somewhere in your life,
you're far more susceptible
to those addictive tendencies.
You're far more easily led to
go and grab that chocolate bar,
or go and have
that glass of wine,
or go and order that takeaway,
or whatever it might be.
And we all do this, right?
We all do this.
But it's just really interesting
to become aware of that
and just observe it.
And hopefully, you can
then heal what it is
that you're really hungry for.
These food product
companies often use this
to their advantage as well.
So they use our emotional
attachments to food
to market to us in
quite subtle ways.
But when you are aware of it,
it really becomes obvious.
For example, have a break.
Have a Kit Kat,
basically saying,
you're life is really tough.
You deserve a break.
Go and take a break and reward
yourself with that Kit Kat.
Or Coca-Cola-- life tastes good.
Go and celebrate
your life by drinking
our carbonated sugary pop drink.
Or Pringles-- once you pop,
you can't stop, basically
normalizing it to eat a
whole tub in one sitting.
Or maybe the worst
culprit of them all,
McDonald's-- are your
kids misbehaving again?
Swing by and get
them a Happy Meal.
That will put a
smile on their face
because it's a
Happy Meal, right?
So before we're
even six years old,
we've already got this
imprinted onto our brains.
The food is there to handle
our emotions, to make us happy,
to numb our pain, which I
just find really interesting.
So I want to do a little
exercise with you guys.
I'd like you to get into pairs.
Just partner up
and don't be shy.
And I just want you to
share with your partner what
that one go-to emotional
food is for you.
It might be crisps or chocolate
or ice cream, chips, cheese,
whatever it might be.
What is that go-to food?
OK.
Everyone done?
Everyone finished?
Guys, just one food.
One food.
Everyone's like, I like this.
I like chocolate.
I like crisps.
I like ice cream.
I like pizza.
OK.
By the way, my
go-to emotional food
when I was really an emotional
eater was always pick and mix.
You know the sweets that you
choose and put in the bag?
That was my thing.
I'm talking I would
go to the cinema
and spend extortionate
amounts on pick and mix
and not even care
about seeing the film.
OK.
So next part of the
exercise, I want
you to think about
what is the earliest
memory of you having that food.
What is the earliest memory
of you having that food?
And share it with your partner.
OK.
Everyone done?
So next, I want you
to just identify
what is the emotion
associated with that memory.
What is the feeling
of that memory?
And share it with your partner.
Not now, but the feeling
associated in that environment
in that memory.
So share it with your partner.
Everyone got that?
OK.
So I'll share mine.
So my earliest memory
of pick and mix
was my mom and dad picking me
up from school on a Friday.
And if I was really good,
then I would get a pound
to spend on pick and mix.
And so that was my favorite
time of the whole week.
And I really looked
forward to that
because I was just so
excited to get that pound.
And so the feeling associated
for me with that memory
was reward and validation
for being good.
And it's a treat.
So in my adult life,
what I've noticed
that I started doing was any
time that I felt like I've been
good or deserved a
reward or a treat,
I would go get
that pick and mix.
My partner, Rick-- his
go-to emotional food
was always Nutella.
And he used to come home
with a jar of Nutella
when he'd had a bad day.
And I'd be like, do we
need to talk about this?
But his earliest
memory of Nutella
was eating it on
pancakes with his mom.
And so he associated that
with love and connection.
So when he felt like he
needed love and connection,
he would go get that
Nutella because food
feels like love, right?
So does anyone want to
share what those were?
Just a couple of people?
Anyone?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Mine was
mac and cheese.
I remember eating it at home
with my mom, my brother,
and my sister just having a
good time, just a happy memory.
MEL WELLS: Yeah.
Yeah.
So then in your adult
life then, if you
feel like you need to
go to a happy place,
that is the happy place.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
MEL WELLS: Yeah, awesome.
Thank you for sharing.
Anyone else want to share?
Everyone's so shy.
Anyone else?
One more?
AUDIENCE: I can share one.
You go because [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Mine was sushi.
And I discovered it when
I was doing a year abroad
in New Orleans,
so when I was 20.
And it was just really
happier and felt really
fun and carefree.
And I ended up
eating it every day.
And it become my cure for
everything-- hangovers.
So it just became this
really joyful thing.
MEL WELLS: So it symbolized
joy, freedom, carefree?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, having
a really fun year.
MEL WELLS: Awesome.
Thank you for sharing.
Another really common thing
is if we weren't allowed it
at home as kids,
then when we grow up
and we're suddenly adults
and free and liberated,
we're like, oh, my God.
I can eat it now.
I'm allowed to eat
whatever I want.
It symbolizes this rebellion and
this freedom and independence.
So food is parallel to our life.
So our relationship
with food can
be this kind of comfort,
this emotional tool.
But it can also be pleasure.
And I think when we get
sucked into diet land,
we forget that we're
allowed to receive
pleasure and joy from food.
It's allowed to be a completely
celebratory experience.
And a good question
to ask yourself
when you're turning to food is,
am I using this to celebrate?
Or am I using it to escape?
Because often, we're actually
trying to push down a feeling.
So our relationship with
food is a reflection
of our relationship
with life, which
means-- you know that saying,
how you do one thing is
how you do everything?
So it's kind of like how you do
food is often how you do life.
So if you are a perfectionist
around your food,
you're probably also a
perfectionist in your life.
If you are controlling
around food,
you're probably also
controlling in life.
And who's an
all-or-nothing person?
Anyone here totally
all-or-nothing?
So if you're
all-or-nothing with food,
you're probably
also all-or-nothing
in your life, in
your relationships,
in your job or projects.
And who here would say
that they are a fast eater?
everyone.
Yeah.
This doesn't surprise me, right?
Because you guys
are high achievers.
So if you're a
fast eater, you're
probably also going
through your life
quite fast, which is why
it's difficult to get people
to slow down their eating.
Because it's
basically like saying,
slow down your life pace.
Do you also drive your car
quite fast if you drive?
Do you go through your life
quite fast in other areas?
Yeah.
So what this means
is when we are
able to heal ourself with food,
we can also heal our life.
And if we're able to enjoy a
more intuitive way of eating,
it means we're more
likely to enjoy
an intuitive way of living.
So I always say intuitive
eating paves the way
for intuitive living.
When I was able to learn how
to really listen to my body,
I was also able to learn
how to listen to my gut.
I was able to learn how
to listen to my intuition.
I realized that the
two went hand in hand.
So a lot of people
think that when
they're going to
listen to their body,
they think that their
body is just telling
them to eat all kinds of junk.
And it's simply not the case.
So I want to explain to
you guys-- just to finish--
the difference between
your real hunger
and your emotional cravings.
So real hunger comes on
very gradually, slowly.
And you feel it here, right?
You feel it in the stomach.
And it gives you the
time and that patience
to go, what am I hungry for?
What am I going to choose
to nourish my body?
Whereas an emotional craving is
actually a psychological need.
And it comes on very
fast in the mind.
And it's that urge.
It's that impulse.
And it usually fixates on
one particular kind of food.
So it comes on really fast.
And if you don't check yourself,
you kind of glaze over.
And you become
this zombie state.
And before you know it,
you've eaten something.
And you don't even
know how you got there.
If we were doing
that with drugs,
it would be a pretty
big problem, right?
But we do that with food a lot.
So when we have those
psychological cravings,
what we're actually craving
is something deeper--
usually love,
usually connection.
And all of those things
that we are craving we
can give to ourselves.
We can never truly
get those needs
met from someone else, a
food, a drink, a substance,
social media, all of these
kind of external things.
It's a way in which we
try to fill ourselves up
from the outside in rather
than filling ourselves
up from the inside
out in fulfillment
and living a truly full-up life.
So thank you.
I hope this has given
you some food for thought
and that you will be able to
hopefully bring a little bit
more awareness to your
relationship with food
and use it to your advantage.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Do we have time for questions?
SPEAKER: So we
have time for Q&A.
You have to speak into
this because we're
recording this for YouTube.
Does anyone have questions?
AUDIENCE: Thank you so much.
I think speaking for all of
us, we all really enjoyed that.
I've got a question,
and I'm not sure
if you're going to
be able to answer it.
But it's to do with the whole
body positive intuitive eating
movement.
Me and a lot of my
friends-- we have
a lot of intolerances, which
really hinders our ability
to eat freely.
And I often feel like that's
not taken into consideration
into the body positive and
intuitive eating movement.
And I would just like to hear
your thoughts on it, really.
Gluten free, dairy
free-- things like that.
MEL WELLS: Sure, sure.
Thank you so much.
So first of all, I
would like to offer
that the body positive
movement is a separate thing
from intuitive eating.
And you can do one without
the other and vice versa.
So I would say that the
body positive movement
is a movement in itself.
And the people that
started that have
their own definition
of what that is
and what they stand for.
But you can decide that for you
to be positive for your body,
for you to show your body
love, means to not have things
that don't agree with it.
So for example, I consider
myself to be body positive
because I do positive
things for my body,
although I'm not a part,
necessarily, of that movement.
And the roots of
it obviously were
different from where I'm sat.
But if doing a positive
thing for your body
is not having certain foods
that don't agree with it,
then that's absolutely great.
I don't think intuitive
eating is about just
eating rubbish all the time.
I think it's about noticing what
feels good and what doesn't.
And that's definitely
something that I've
learned along my journey.
Because I thought that
going into intuitive eating
would mean that I would
just gain loads of weight
and would just sit around
eating donuts and ice cream
and all kinds of
cereal for dinner
and all this kind of stuff.
And it's not what happened.
I think initially, there
might be a boomerang phase
where you're just like
oh, my God, freedom.
But then after that,
what happens is you start
to recognize what feels
good and what doesn't.
And you start to notice
that, actually, it
feels really good to have
this amount of vegetables.
And it feels really good to
have meat or to not have meat.
And it feels really good to have
gluten or to not have gluten.
And it's really about you taking
your power back around food
and not thinking that it
has to look a certain way.
It's about you becoming
the boss of your own body.
AUDIENCE: Thank you so much.
That was good.
SPEAKER: Any other questions?
AUDIENCE: Hi, yes.
Thank you so much for the talk.
I just wanted to know
a little bit more
if you're comfortable sharing.
You talked about your veganism
and your perfectionism
to the state that you are now.
We all know the path to whatever
kind of looks like this--
and if you had a few of these
tips or how you overcame those
and how you also got to the
state that you're in now.
MEL WELLS: Yeah, sure.
Do you mean from disordered
or from veganism--
AUDIENCE: From just sort of
eating [INAUDIBLE] to how
you are present.
MEL WELLS: Yeah, sure.
So it was definitely a
bumpy road to begin with.
Because when you are so
ingrained in that diet culture,
you feel like a lot of your
identity is wrapped up in it.
So I don't really know
who I was without a diet
because it consumed
so much of my life.
So giving myself that freedom
to break free from that
felt like I was
rediscovering who I was
and almost creating a
new identity for myself.
Because it had taken
up so much head space
that when I got rid of that,
I was like, oh, my God.
I don't know what to
do with myself anymore.
It was like a full-time
job for me, dieting.
So coming out of that was
definitely a bumpy road.
But I just kept focusing on,
I'm getting my life back here.
So even though to begin
with I gained weight,
I also gained my life back,
which was so much more
important to me.
But yeah, I definitely
had to figure out
all of these different
beliefs and stories
that I was telling myself
around different diets and food
and the people that I followed.
I had to unfollow
a lot of people
that were projecting their
beliefs out onto social media.
And I was like, that's
not helpful for me
for where I'm at right now.
I just need to be able to make
my own intuitive decisions
around food rather
than listening
to every single
expert that's got
a different opinion on food.
I just needed to
block all that out
to just come home to my body.
And that really helped me.
But for sure, it
was a bumpy road.
And yeah, I realized
along that road
that veganism wasn't
for me anymore.
And me deciding to be a vegan--
my intention behind that
wasn't as it should have been.
It was because I thought
it was the perfect diet
and because I thought it
would heal me and make
me lose weight as opposed
to what actually feels good.
And I have a lot of
friends that are vegan.
But they do it for much
more ethical reasons.
But personally,
for me, I feel good
when I have a bit of animal
products in my lifestyle.
And I don't think anyone
should be shamed for that.
SPEAKER: Well, thanks
again, Mel, for coming.
MEL WELLS: Cool.
Thanks for having me.
[APPLAUSE]